foreign
let's go to Kayla
you got me on my knees Kayla in
Winchester what's up Kayla
a guy picked me up at a bar one time
like that did it work
Ed uh I don't remember
probably
that means yeah
that means yes
that's fantastic sister what's up
um well my question is should I write my
mom's therapist a letter
ah tell me more
um
I'm well I went no contact with her why
this past summer
um I wanted off the crazy train I don't
know how else to put it sorry no hey
we're don't be sorry at all sometimes we
all are going off the rails on the crazy
train good for you
so
um
she has a really traumatic past okay
and would remind you of that constantly
and she finally did reach out and get
help and I was really proud of her for
that
um but she just kept disrespecting that
I wanted to go no contact with her I was
just done
um how is she disrespecting you give me
an example
well
we got to a point in our relationship
where like I said I wanted off the crazy
train just couldn't do it anymore what
does that mean tell me give me some
specifics
getting really specific so I asked too
much of her and really my father at the
same time so
um my husband and I were living in a
house that was too small for our family
and we decided to get with my parents
um for them to let us build a house on
property that they were going to give to
us like they did for my older brother
and they have a pretty big piece of land
so we paid for the survey the lane was
feeding it over to us my dad is a
general contractor he was supposed to be
helping us build the house
well tumultuous situation after
tumultuous situation we actually moved
in with them because we sold our house
and was living in their four bedroom
Farmhouse we kind of had our own space
they tried really hard I guess not to
cramp our style and vice versa but my
mom just kept spinning out
she
um flew off the handle because she was
missing a notebook one day and she
thought I had this notebook like it's
always been
um
just something small that just sets her
off and I mean she goes she goes off the
wall about things and she would spin out
and it would just remind me of my
childhood where her and my father would
just fight constantly and that's how I
grew up okay so so hold on why
or do you still live in her house
no they kicked us out after a month okay
they actually told us to get the F out
okay so y'all got the F out and you got
a new place you and your husband
yes okay so why the no contact or why
don't you just block her on your phone
and go about your day go about your life
all right did you get your money back
for the house mess
um we
timing of it was really bizarre I didn't
we only ended up losing about ten
thousand dollars
when it was all said and done the
property is so deeded to us and we just
so we don't know what to do with it so
my husband doesn't feel like it's
appropriate to do that
well
that's between y'all too
right
you want to put your daughter in this
crazy mess no no no she's only three but
we think in our minds my husband Minds
that that's going to be her property one
day why in the world would you want
another one of your family members to go
back to that chaos I know they started
crazy well sell it go about your life
move
it's a crazy thing about America you can
live wherever you want to do whatever
you want
there's something about this situation
where you are choosing
misery
like like
no let me say it this way I don't think
you're choosing misery
I think you've heard me say probably if
you ever listen to this show choose
guilt over resentment
I think you chose guilt the right thing
to do
and I think it's killing you
yeah because I have
outside
factors be like you only have one set of
parents you need to work it out with
them I'm and I tell these people no
Kayla Kayla Kayla
none of those people get a vote
your mom and your dad have proven
themselves to be unsafe people to be
around
and every time you listen to another
voice you're deciding yeah I'm just
gonna go get my head kicked in for a few
minutes
and I for one I don't practice MMA
anymore I haven't in a long time so I
don't choose to get my head kicked on a
regular basis anymore
you shouldn't either
they don't get a vote
I mean
I've tried to set up boundaries you know
I told them to give me time after all of
that that was just a terrible situation
you gotta put my family in
and she came back and this was verbatim
your dad is very upset about this and if
we're not worthy to be a part of your
family we want our family's land back
well because I don't know what to do he
cries all the time this is very sad he
doesn't have many years left and you're
stealing more like placing all the guilt
on me about this entire situation she's
been around and told people that I'm the
one with the problem Kayla Kayla Kayla
Kayla Kayla
you've heard the old the old wives tale
about the uh the rattlesnake in the
paper bag
you ever heard that
so there was a guy who had a
it's all rattlesnake on the ground and
he picked it up and scooped it into a
plastic bag into a paper bag and
the rattlesnake said hey thanks man I
really appreciate you
um
I'd like it love it if you I got an itch
in the back of my head I can't scratch
it I'd love it if you scratched that
itch for me the guy was like sure man
and he reached in the bag to scratch
that itch and the rattlesnake bit him
and he's like what do you why'd you do
that and he's like well I'm a
rattlesnake that's what I do
and guys like that was the meanest thing
I was just kind to you and whatever he's
like I know I'm around saying this is
what I do
and then a little while later the
rattlesnake's like hey man I'm sorry
that was that's 100 on me my bad I need
to overcome that um but I still get that
crazy itch we please get it and the
guy's like no last time you bit me and
he's like I know I know anyway he
reached in to scratch him again and it
bites him again he goes I told you I'm a
rattlesnakes what'd I do
and at that point
the second bite on is that guy's fault
because he keeps putting his hand back
in the bag
foreign
demonstrated that she does not want to
be in relationship with you
she wants you as a proxy to make her
husband feel less crappy because she
can't do it
she wants you in their life so that they
have a punching bag other than each
other
but she doesn't want a relationship with
you a loving mother-daughter
relationship and I hate that for you
because that's one of the most precious
relationships in the world well it's
never been there right why are you
continuing why are you continuing to
scream and fight for it because she will
not leave me alone about it no
no I don't know what that is
I thought you said you gave her no con
oh you went no contact you just blocked
her you haven't called the police and
said I want a no contact order filed on
this woman
no I never did that okay you can do that
and make it illegal for her to come to
your house or to contact you
if she refuses to accept your boundaries
you can go one step further
and there's nothing in her the way she's
she's acted towards you that would make
me think that she's one day gonna get it
that's right
and I mean she showed up two weeks ago
to invite me to another therapy
appointment which would be sitting down
next to her with her therapist which
just seems insane
she actually was level-headed talking to
me she was still saying the same things
but she was level at least level-headed
and she didn't seem high and I was like
well maybe there is some hope in this
but she still was saying the same thing
blaming other people for her actions
she's she just doesn't take any
accountability Kayla you've
you've gotta
I know it's frustrating I can't even
imagine
and I know it's heartbreaking I can't
even imagine
but every time she shows up you sound
surprised
and every time she shows up your body is
experiencing this as though it's
happened it happened the first time oh
yeah if I just take off yeah
so until you can be safe your body will
chill out around her you gotta create
space
and that might mean you talk this over
with your husband but that might mean
you let her know
I've asked you repeatedly for some space
for you to stop showing up at my house
for you to stop calling me and blaming
at me for everything going on in your
home
I'm happy to sell you this land back or
if quite honestly if it was me I would
probably dust my hands off and give them
a stupid land back and because they have
clearly made it the dirt is more
important than you
I'll repeat that that dirt is more
important than you in Your gran in their
grandkid your kid and your husband
here's the dirt back bye
my life is too short
feel how you feel right now
at this point forward
you're choosing to put your hand back in
the bag and get bit over and over and
over again
I would make One Last Stand and say if
you come again I'm going to contact the
police I'm going to file a no contact
order
I don't want you on my property I don't
want you calling me I don't want you to
connecting with me at this time I will
reach back out to you when I feel ready
and answer your original question yes
um
her counselor
if she's has any ethics at all cannot
even tell you that she's seeing her as a
client can't even acknowledge that this
person is a counselor I mean a client of
mine but she can receive information and
data from outside sources so absolutely
I think it'd be great to send a letter
I think this stuff's always healthy
that'd be wonderful don't expect any
sort of return from the therapist the
therapist would you should file this
therapist should lose their license if
she writes you back is what I'm saying
um other than to say I've received your
note thank you anything beyond that like
uh this is for your mom that's great
but yeah send it send it
and ask yourself this question
how long am I gonna avoid the hard part
which is grieving the fact that my mom
is choosing these other things over me
and instead of choosing That season of
grief that you're going to have to go
through one way or another
you're choosing to get bit over and over
and over again
this sounds crazy but choose grief
choose heartbreak for a season
because on the other side of grief on
the other side of heartbreak
that Kayla is where healing is